foreign
okay
councilor Leicester I was actually going
to make an exception at the same point
that it feels very unfair that
um someone just based on age is actually
because it's still based on years um
service but you get half less for the
fact that you're younger it ties into
minimum wage as well because you've got
the same issue there which I know we're
not responsible for minimum wage but
it's a reflection it doesn't reflect
that people can be doing the same work
just
differently just because they've aged
differently and what I actually wanted
to ask was I don't think I really quite
understand what these payments are
because they're not they're not
redundancy payments so it's separate
from the redundancy process so this it
seems to be the